y
[Música]
fracasa otra tentativa del presidente de
donald trump de desconocer los
resultados electorales el tribunal
supremo de eeuu rechazó la demanda
presentada por el estado de texas que
pretendía revocar el resultado de los
comicios presidenciales del pasado 3 de
noviembre que le dieron la victoria al
demócrata joe biden tenemos información
de este washington
en argentina la cámara de diputados
apruebe el proyecto de ley de aborto
hasta las 14 semanas de gestación pero
todavía debe ser sancionado por el
senado el texto que fue impulsado por el
gobierno de alberto fernández recibió
131 votos a favor 117 en contra y 6
abstenciones tras una sesión que se
extendió por 20 horas
inmersa en su crisis más grave en los
últimos 30 años jugó emprende la recta
final hacia la unificación de sus dos
monedas el primero de enero de 2021
en esta fecha desaparecerá el peso
cubano convertible e moneda artificial
la paritaria con el dólar y quedará como
única denominación legal el peso cubano
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se redoblan
con gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en eeuu donde el tribunal
supremo rechazó este viernes la demanda
presentada por texas para reeducar el
resultado de los comicios presidenciales
el pasado 3 de noviembre que le dieron
la victoria al demócrata joe biden en su
escrito la alta instancia judicial
señaló que texas no ha demostrado un
interés judicialmente reconocible sobre
la manera en otros estados en que otros
estados llevaron a cabo estas elecciones
y para conocer más detalles salud en
este momento a nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal la buena
noche fracasó el presidente de una trama
en su estrategia legal al confiarse en
lo que iba a decidir la corte suprema y
la influencia además que trató de
ejercer sobre ésta
raúl buenas noches y fracaso porque pues
recordemos que el presidente trump e
incluso antes de las elecciones estaba
diciendo que esta elección presidencial
la iba a llevar a la corte suprema que
sería la corte suprema que se podría
definir esta elección en caso que él las
perdiera de hecho por eso avanzó y
apresuró el nombramiento de emi con y
barrett como magistrada a la corte
suprema recordemos que durante los
cuatro años que él estuvo en la
presidencia fueron tres los magistrados
que logró pues nombrar en la corte
suprema- precisamente con el fin de
ganar batallas legales y entonces poder
en este caso pues definir la elección
que no ganó en las urnas poderla definir
en las cortes
donald trump trató incluso además de
demandar a nivel estatal en los
organismos electorales pidió recorte os
y se gastó mucha plata plata que fue
financiado por sus propios simpatizantes
para hacer esta campaña de
cuestionamiento de las elecciones que
obviamente no
logra ganar y que no logra ganar lo
tanto en las urnas sino que ahora
tampoco en las cortes lo que están
diciendo los expertos sin embargo es que
el presidente troupe pues quiere seguir
con esta batalla legal y que incluso se
vienen pues todavía más demandas
precisamente para pues seguir con el
apoyo legal el apoyo popular de parte de
su gente
cristóbal qué posibilidades tienen ahora
a donald trump de seguir luchando
legalmente para desconocer estos
resultados electorales
pues raúl lo que están diciendo los
medios es que se vienen demandas
demandas incluso lideradas por reducción
y que es el alba lo principal de donald
trump para pues seguir precisamente esto
generando ruido generando más apoyo
popular resentimiento y generando más
dudas sobre las elecciones con el fin de
mantener ese ese poder político que le
servirá a donald trump los próximos
cuatro años para ganarse a elecciones
locales o incluso como se dice para
poder aspirar en cuatro años nuevamente
a la presidencia pero este es el máximo
órgano legislativo y haber ya tomado
esta decisión por parte de la corte
suprema simplemente lo dejas sin base
para sus aspiraciones de mantenerse en
la casa blanca durante cuatro años más
cristóbal como siempre gracias por toda
la información que nos ofrece desde la
capital estadounidense creció al base es
corresponsal de france 24 en washington
dice y seguimos en eeuu donde el
presidente electo joe biden nombró a
susan rice él como directora del consejo
de política interna de la casa
lo que le da una amplia influencia sobre
el enfoque de su administración en
materia de inmigración atención médica y
desigualdad racial la medida marca un
cambio para raíz una experta demócrata
en política exterior que se desempeñó
como asesora de seguridad nacional del
presidente barack obama y embajadora de
la onu trabajó en estrecha colaboración
con el entonces vicepresidente biden en
estos roles y estaba en su lista para
convertirse en su compañera de fórmula
durante la campaña 2020 pero que hay un
giro también con la elección de cámara
javier finalmente que un su gabinete
y también en eeuu el jefe de gabinete de
la casa blanca mark meadows se pidió a
stephen hunt el jefe de la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos
efe de a que dimita si esa agencia no
autoriza hoy la vacuna contra el cob y
19 desarrollada por facer by un check el
diario washington post indicó que esta
amenaza ha provocado que la fed haya
adelantado su calendario para dar el
visto bueno a la vacuna este 12 de
diciembre por su parte el presidente
saliente de donald trump criticó a la
sda en twitter a la que calificó como
una tortuga grande vieja y lenta e instó
a sacar como dice él las malditas
vacunas ahora
y la marea verde argentina está un paso
más cerca de celebrar sus
reivindicaciones con la aprobación y la
aprobación del proyecto de ley sobre la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
la cámara de diputados si el texto es
finalmente sancionado toda gestante
podrá acceder al sistema de salud al
aborto legal gratuito dentro del plazo
de 14 semanas ahora el foco está de
nuevo puesto sobre el senado que será
encargado de decidir si aprueba esta ley
y que ya en 2018 rechazó un proyecto
similar veamos el informe de marina
sardina
resultado 131 votos afirmativos 117
negativos
atención resulta afirmativo cánticos de
aborto legal abrazos y lágrimas la marea
verde celebra con vítores del resultado
de la votación del proyecto de ley sobre
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
después de más de 20 horas de intenso
debate legislativo ahora la última
palabra para la despenalización del
aborto en argentina la tiene el senado
la sección de diputados dijeron que
los votos estarían en el senado porque
el dictamen que salió ahora con la media
sanción está hablado también con
senadores entonces por lo que dijeron
los mismos diputados tendríamos un buen
resultado también en el senado un
obstáculo que las feministas de la
campaña nacional por el derecho legal
seguro y gratuito saben que no será
fácil debido a la fuerte presión de los
grupos religiosos y conservadores en el
senado cuyos miembros representan las
provincias y por el apoyo de los
activistas anti derechos celestes algo
que refleja las divisiones que este tema
ha hecho salir a flote en argentina
donde también muchas mujeres con
pañuelos celestes se han manifestado en
contra de la ley el proyecto impulsado
por la presidencia contempla la
despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 14 del embarazo además los
profesionales que intervengan en la
interrupción del embarazo tendrán
derecho a ejercer la objeción de
conciencia' pero deberán derivar de
buena fe a la paciente a otro
profesional una cláusula que los
pañuelos verdes no aprueban no estamos
de acuerdo
de hecho nosotros creemos que esto sirve
solo para obturar en algunos lugares que
se efectivicen pero bueno seguiremos
dando con la militancia por otra parte
con una amplia mayoría los legisladores
aprobaron el plan de los mil días de
protección integral de la mujer
embarazada hasta los tres primeros años
de infancia el feminismo argentino
confía que el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo sea una realidad
antes de fin de año
un día antes de celebrarse los cinco
años del acuerdo de parís unión europea
aumentó su compromiso para hacerle
frente al cambio climático al prometer
este viernes que reducirá sus emisiones
de efecto invernadero en 55% en lugar de
los 40 ya acordados
sequías olas de calor y pandemias a
medida que se intensifican las
consecuencias del cambio climático
también lo hacen los esfuerzos para
frenarlo la unión europea acordó reducir
en al menos 55 por ciento las emisiones
de efecto invernadero para 2030
comparadas con los niveles de 1990 ese
es un salto respecto al objetivo previo
del 40 por ciento en un intento por
alcanzar cero emisiones para el 2050 ya
que las emisiones de efecto invernadero
son la principal causa del cambio
climático
todos los países de la unión europea
deberían beneficiarse de la transición
con crecimiento económico con un
medioambiente más limpio y ciudadanos
más saludables será nuestra estrategia
de crecimiento scratch y el acuerdo
significa que los renovables duplicarán
su participación en la producción de
energía
el bloque invertirá 350 mil millones de
euros extras en energía baja en carbono
se fomentarán más autos eléctricos y la
unión europea- restringirá a los
permisos de carbono por lo que
contaminar les saldrá más costoso a las
empresas las nuevas medidas llegan un
día antes del quinto aniversario del
acuerdo de parís
con esta demostración de distanciamiento
social la arquitecta de los acuerdos
dice que muy poco se ha hecho para
contrarrestar la emergencia climática
el ciclo de vida es claro que los
gobiernos están oyendo a quienes no
quieren el cambio a menudo las compañías
emplean a muchas personas que son ducto
zizou y con eso también se trata de lo
que ellos saben este tipo de política de
ecología económica es nuevo es por eso
que esto desconecta y retrasa después de
indicar la xviii ley el proyecto de
carbono global reveló este viernes que
las emisiones en 2020 cayeron un récord
de 7 por ciento debido a la pandemia
pero que sin la transición verde esta
reducción será un destello pasajero
el parlamento de azerbaiyán levanta la
ley marcial a un mes del fin de la
guerra en la disputada región de nagorno
karabaj enfrentó a las fuerzas de ese
país con las y armenia adrià rocha
periodista de france 24 está en
azerbaiyán ilícito oficial y un poblado
capturado por los armenios en la primera
guerra del amor no trabaje en 1993 y
ahora ocupada por azerbaiyán conozcamos
cómo es hoy ese lugar
esto en otra época era una zona
residencial cuando en armenia azerbaiyán
reinaba la unión soviética pero en 1988
esta violenta guerra entre ambos que
terminó en el 94 con una victoria
armenia y este mismo territorio la
región de friuli acabó conquistada por
soldados armenios este sitio al que me
encuentro ahora mismo que era una zona
residencial como comentábamos fue
convertido en un cuartel general de los
soldados armenios en la región una
región donde antes de esta primera
guerra del karabaj nunca habían vivido
soldados armenios y sólo vivían la
población a hacer y que fue expulsada de
siete esta y otras seis regiones que
envuelven en la oroya lava que es la
región concreta por la que a félix y
armenios disputan esta localidad este
mismo sitio ahora ha sido reconvertido
en el cuartel general de hacer is de
soldados a celis y fue luchado ferviente
fervientemente entre las tropas de ambos
países para llegar a controlar este
pequeño trozo como se ve a varios coches
y varios agujeros de bala también los
edificios siguen aquí como también
siguen muchos objetos de los armenios
que antes estaban aquí
destinados militarmente hemos visto
incluso algunos algo
de photo dvds películas y todo tipo de
objetos que pertenecían antes a los
armenios que fueron obligados a
marcharse por la guerra de esta región
como no muchas otras fue luchado durante
el conflicto otras regiones después del
autor fuego asignado el 10 de noviembre
de este mismo año fueron entregadas
desde armenia azerbayán como son acdam
que el bayern y la ching cuba anunció la
unificación monetaria a partir del
primero de enero del 21 para poner fin a
más de tres décadas de circulación
paralela el peso cubano y el peso
convertible la medida supone la primera
devaluación del peso cubano desde la
revolución de 1959
y 2021 con una sola moneda en
circulación desde el primero de enero
cuba eliminará el peso convertibles que
se cotizaba a un dólar y dejará solo el
peso cubano a una tasa oficial única de
24 pesos por dólar la medida largamente
esperada supone la primera devaluación
de la moneda desde la revolución de 1959
aunque menos severa de lo que se temía
así el gobierno busca simplificar el
sistema monetario y cambiario y generar
mejores condiciones comerciales para
impulsar la golpeada economía de la isla
ya se ha expresado que la tarea
ordenamiento no constituye por sí misma
la solución mágica a todos los problemas
presentes en nuestra economía
sin embargo favorecerá la creación de
las condiciones necesarias para avanzar
de manera más sólida
el principal temor frente a la reforma
es que se dispare la inflación
aunque el gobierno garantizó que habrá
medidas de contención para evitar los
precios abusivos y sanciones severas
para quienes incumplan pese a que
tendrán seis meses para cambiar sus
pesos convertibles los cubanos se
formaron largas filas para comenzar ese
proceso el anuncio del gobierno trajo
reacciones mixtas para el lugar que ésta
acepta una moneda del lugar que aceptan
otras pienso que a tener una sola moneda
puedo hacer más
a partir de todo esto se va a poner malo
malo malo
por qué
suben los salarios pero en realidad
si todo sube ya vimos los precios de la
corriente que son impagables al final y
la calidad de vida va a disminuir cada
vez más para amortiguar el impacto la
reforma monetaria incluirá la
quintuplicación del salario mínimo que
pasará de 1787 dólares
el ajuste de las pensiones y la
eliminación de subsidios excesivos y
gratuidades indebidas
hasta aquí el informativo continúe con
nosotros buena noche
[Música]